all right so this is this show where
people of all ages have been like Jeremy
you should watch arrow watch it watch it
watch it watch it watch it watch and I
had never watched it but I'm gonna be on
the masters of web comic-con panel this
year with Manu Bennett aka Slade Wilson
from arrow aka Deathstroke so I was like
I've never seen arrow so I guess I
should do my homework and watch arrow
I enjoyed it so damn much I was like now
I want to talk about season 1 of arrow
arrow season 1 yeah I haven't watched
season 2 yet because it's not on Netflix
it's not out on blu-ray so all I have a
season 1 so arrows a show on the CW that
is about the comic book character green
arrow immediately I was like you mean
that dude who was a side character and
small but no thank you
I enjoyed Smallville when I was younger
and I look older and I spent 10 weeks
out of the year in a row in Westeros I
survived the red wedding pitch me on how
a show on the CW about superheroes is
gonna be good but I guess I don't know
everything and that's me jumping to
conclusions because I actually had a
good time with it because people never
properly pitched to me how arrow would
be interesting and I will pitch it to
you because I know you people here my
people this is how people should have
described it to me so the show starts
out you see Oliver Queen on this island
he's been shipwrecked on an island for a
few years he has the long hair the beard
he looks like green arrow as you would
know green arrow and he gets off the
island and then back into civilization
and he has a list of names and he's
going to right the wrongs that his
really corrupt ass family did he comes
from a rich family so imagine Bruce
Wayne gets back and he was like Oh
Thomas Wayne was a dick I have to right
the wrongs and take out the people who
you know screwed the city with him and
now he's on a total vigilante hunt for
these people who have screwed his city
seriously in an awesome way he will have
them dead to rights with his bow and
arrow and he'll be like you whatever
your name is you have failed this city
and he'll kill him right there I was
like you are not Bruce Wayne yeah you
may have gone away for a few years and
came back completely efficient at
killing things like Bruce Wayne who
never actually kills things but the most
intriguing part of arrow is the
revelation of the plot it's like Reverse
loss Deena how flash has reverse flash
this is Reverse loss on loss they're
trapped on an island but every episode
it shows flashbacks to them on the
mainland it expands their character
makes them interesting in arrow he's on
the mainland but in every episode it
shows flashbacks of him on the island
and expands his character and makes him
interesting shows how he became so I
don't even know how he became so
efficient at everything
the dude comes back speaking Russian I
was like oh where are the Russians don't
know it somehow I'll find out Linda
maybe if they haven't forgotten ya the
first half of season 1 of arrow it's
pretty episodic I heard that was the
boring half of the season but I had a
lot of fun with it it was just him going
vigilante taking out people who screwed
the city that's fun to me I like
vigilantism but in the next few episodes
after the first half that's actually
when I start backing up and go whoa you
start finding out who Oliver Queen is
and that is the green arrow and I was
like I don't want or the hood as they
call him in the show but I didn't want
to see that keep the mystery I don't
want the mystery to be lost however in
that midseason mark that's when his
adventure on the island gets a lot
cooler and that's when I'm like actually
I prefer Atlas let's see a lot more
Island no smoke monster yet but I'm
banking on it but then the last few
episodes of the first season you're like
alright there's the whole overarching
story that's going to carry into season
2 it was actually pretty intense that I
left off on yep that's a cliffhanger
because some of that love back and forth
romance love triangle nonsense in the
show but everything has a romance Batman
Begins had a romance that's another
thing maybe they borrowed a bit from
Batman Begins for sure from the tone
first of all I like the tone Oliver
Queen I as I know him in the comic books
this is really sarcastic ass and I like
that in this show he's not like that but
I get it you want to make them darker
and brooding because people are into
that now you would have to get a
really good actor to pull off that kind
of comedy who's also pretty enough to
get the checks coming back that's really
hard to do I get it it's just easier to
make him dark and brooding and it's also
interesting so why not and the whole him
being gone for a few years and then
coming back then the end there's this
plot element and season one run like
that's like something that happened in
Batman Begins and maybe they just
borrowed a bit from it because it's safe
smart yes safe yeah but in that I did
like the tone a lot that tone is one of
the things that brought me into it I'm
like okay I I like this show I want to
see where the show goes I'm not going to
turn the show off let's just marathon
the show you think superhero show on the
CW you don't think the tone of the show
this show has the tone that I hope
Gotham has there's also not one
unattractive chick in this show every
female in the show is swear to God is
hot hot chick hot chick hot chick hot
chick hot chick hot chick even his mom
is hot seriously there's not one on a
Trevor eat I'm a female's on-screen
emoji yep you could be in a calendar
they could have a calendar called the
chicks of arrow it even has like Easter
eggs I heard everything right everything
I'm going to say about season 1 of arrow
I heard is amplified in season 2 so when
I say there are really cool comic book
DC Universe Easter eggs and season 1 I
know there are 10 foals in season 2 I'm
just saying as it stands there are
really cool ones in season 1 like
they're these villains where I'm like is
that a real
look it up on my phone I'm like yep
that's actually a villain why do I
recognize from Arkham origins I was like
is that dude from Arkham it's the dude
from Arkham origins to be honest my main
gripe with the show is something that
the show couldn't escape because it's on
the CW in the sense that it's not on AMC
or HBO so it's going to be 23 episodes
long when you're dealing with 23
episodes in one season you're gonna have
downtime you're going to have episodes
where it's like it's going to be
episodic it's not really relevant to the
overall plot it's going to be filler he
had 12 to 14 episodes per season you'd
have a really solid season because
they'd be like we have to use every
episode to the fullest every episode
would be optimized to be time efficient
you'd walk away going there's just
nothing irrelevant about that entire
season so season 1 of arrow I enjoyed a
lot it's a bit episodic but episodic in
that he's taken out dudes because he's a
vigilante and that's still interesting
as episodic as it may be maybe one of
the elements that gets you through the
episodic phase of this show is the fact
that everyone's like Susan do so awesome
and I'm really looking forward to that
they show surprised me I feel like
it's convincing people to watch arrow
because it's not your common CW teen
romance superhero show
it's like convincing people to watch
Battlestar Gallactica because it's not a
normal-size I show in the Sci Fi Channel
it's like those arguments never go
anywhere because everyone's always like
yeah they are watch the pilot episode
cuz the pilot episode is a solid pilot
episode that was the episode Rose like
yeah I want to watch more yeah it
started out as homework so I would know
the work of Manu Bennett when I meet him
at Comic Con but I finished it as
something I was enjoying doing I'm
marathon all of season one and two days
and the fact that Slade Wilson didn't go
full Deathstroke in this season kind of
made it counterproductive to the reason
I started this whole adventure as long
as I enjoy my time and as long as I
enjoy my 23 hours of televisions not a
waste to me I don't have a rating for
shows but you can do what I did I have
Netflix and I watched season one on
Netflix and I enjoyed watching it on
Netflix so arrow season one have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you